hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of e3 2019 I'm Mike Mahoney
here with Lucy James hello and we are
pleased to be joined by that says does
Todd Howard you are here at the show
talking about a few different things but
largely fallout 76
first off how's the show going for you
especially now that Bethesda's
conferences is done and you can just
kind of like finish everything else off
it's great III I think is one of the
best times of the year and it's great
not just for myself or those of us have
been thesan but I think really for the
whole industry gets a lot of attention
there's so many amazing games when
you're here this e3 is if I'm not
mistaken a first for you in the sense
that you're coming on to talk about an
ongoing game right this is the first
time that you personally launched one in
the team the Fez a game studio just
launched one and yes a form of Fallout
76 does that is III feel as different as
I imagined it would for you well usually
in the we are big game Skyrim or a
fallout we're doing DLC you know and the
III after this one's different where
we've been updating the game on a kind
of a constant basis and so it's nice
where we're having a free week for
everybody you know we know the game got
had a lot of issues that launched
affected a lot of players and it's nice
for us to say hey you know check it out
now we're having a free week and a lot
of great updates this week with the game
and then this fall I mean to piggyback
off that on the launch of fallout 76 and
recently in interviews you've been very
candid about you know the reception and
what you're all working on to kind of
improve the experience of players what's
that been like is a process for you know
it's a game that you guys have worked on
for years and you're very very close to
it and then seeing it be out in the
public and the reaction perhaps being
different to what you expected
definitely you know we were caught off
guard with the amount of issues that
that we had and the amount of people
that that affected and our fans I tell
you are the best
usually that might sync again and we're
blessed and lucky enough to have fans to
say we love this we're going to support
you here are the issues got a lot of
criticism obviously that look
we deserved it's a game that we should
have had in a longer beta test that ran
24/7 for our players but they've been
amazing and it's been that was hard but
it's also been really special for us in
that we now have a better engaged
dialogue with our fans were able to
update the game one week and they tell
us what they like and that's just a
continuing process so that that kind of
bond with the people playing the game
has meant you know a tremendous amount
to us I mean but making video games as
hard as hell in general but I imagine
releasing fall at 76 and like you said
criticism was well deserved in some
respects I imagine it still must have
been kind of mentally emotionally
challenging for a lot of the team to
release this thing that they worked on
and to get a lot of criticism what was
that like for you guys it's definitely
hard you know it's a game that we love
it's something different and we missed
the mark on on a number of things so
yeah I think it's important as a creator
that you listen to that feedback that
comes with it we've gotten great stuff
in the past and our fans are very very
passionate obviously it means a lot to
us so it's hey hey what do we need to do
we're not gonna we're not going to go
away we're we're passionate about the
game and where it's headed and and want
to do right by everybody who bought it
and that believes in what we were trying
to do how do you go about having that
open dialogue I mean there are some
issues that are pronounced you know with
regard to bugs and things but when it
comes to making changes to gameplay how
do you filter out the noise so to speak
because you're gonna have these
thousands and thousands of people
offering their input how do you deal
with that with you know comparing it to
what's realistic it's an excellent
question you know we still aim high
right so we listen to all of it and then
say hey where does that match up with
what we're feeling as well and then what
can we do like adding the NPC's to the
game with wastelanders that was
something that we started looking at
right when the game was coming out like
okay if we did do this how would it work
and then when we got that feedback that
hey this this feels like a lonely
multiplayer game like okay how do we how
do we address that and it became a
higher priority to can we make the NPC's
where
can we do the dialogue trees can we make
those choices you're doing have meaning
in a game that is at the end of the day
an instanced kind of multiplayer game
and so we found some creative solutions
to that that we started feeling good
about so hey we should do this
adding NPCs is a big deal what are some
other priorities that you have for the
game like what's pressing on your mind
right now
really--it's and the whole thing about
it was we love these other online games
whether their survival ones or whatever
where there's a community where what the
game is is determined by what the
players in the world are doing and so
we're still looking for things that
connect people so the player vending
systems been really popular where the
you're really starting to visit other
people's camps and we have a lot of
other ideas like that that aren't just
NPCs that say hey this world has life
some of that we're gonna have to bring
to it with NPCs but we still want the
bulk of that to be the other players
whether they are creating things or
adventuring together I think a good way
to say it is we've u76 as somewhat of a
platform for Fallout where as we did it
before and then you had mod systems that
this is something that's gonna be going
on not just this year we have plans for
future years and a lot of that is how do
we give the players more agency I'm
curious you know like moving forward 76
obviously like you want you want you're
adding NPCs with wastelanders right
you're you then you have the nuclear
winter mode which is adding like a new
way to play fallout 76 what is it like
in the future say a year from now where
do you want to follow 76 to be well I
think we're adding these things that
give it a full flip you know more ways
people can play and engage with it I
think long term for us and it's it's a
ways out is still servers that you can
are private you can mod for us the
modding community is huge it's been huge
for Skyrim and fallout 4 I think we just
announced crossed a billion downloads of
mods which is just is that a real number
it's incredible so when it comes to you
know looking ahead I think in terms of
your pipeline as a game director you
know last year you kind of revealed you
know Elder Scrolls six star field how do
you go from one project to another how
do you know when it's time to kind of
let the reins go on fallout 76 a little
bit to actually move on I mean my job
has changed somewhat now that we've
scaled up we have the four studios we're
four hundred people whereas we used to
just be just over a hundred in Rockville
where I am and so some of them it
depends on the week that I act as
executive producer and then a game like
Star field is one that right now you
know it when it starts and then even now
I'm more heavily involved in on it on a
day-to-day basis that's a that's a very
very new thing and we have we have a lot
of people have been doing this for a
while and so you know particularly with
76 nuclear winter was done by a group in
several studios we had a bunch of people
in Dallas and Austin other places and so
you know my job is to support them and
we all we all work together there are
some of these subsets I read every
really interesting stories about these
communities that have popped up in
Fallout 76 I think my favorite recently
I forget who wrote it I think it might
have been on Kotaku but it was about
this group of cannibals in the game that
like that they have this community that
if you become a cannibal they help I saw
the headline I started reading I was
like which way is this story gonna go
yeah yeah so is it bad good funny or is
it bad disturbing yeah and that's like
that's to me that's that was the dream
when I first heard of the idea fallout
76 it is a game a platformer I could go
into and create those worlds with people
that I kind of had to just create on my
own and fallout 3 and Fallout 4 right
I'm just curious like I don't know what
is it like seeing these kind of these
niche groups pop up throughout fall of
76 of @sq we had some of that before
like with the mods but it wasn't
isolated our community was you
downloading things and then talking
about it outside of the game so it's
been great for us where people can
finally do those activities inside of
the game looking back when fall is 76
released do you think in the last year
or so or maybe before it released would
you if you could go back in time would
you change anything about the way you
communicated it about anything I mean I
know that's like a loaded question
because I'm sure every development team
would say oh yeah we would have done
this this week but in terms of
communicating the idea fall at 76 you
have any regrets about that
my main regret is not doing a beta that
a lot of people could play like if we
had made it free for every fallout 4
player and run a 24/7 beta for a longer
period of time that would have let us
see okay what are we really dealing with
here the betas we did were concentrated
because we were worried about peak
concurrency so that but they were so we
got those issues solved but didn't get a
good look at how does the game really
behave at scale 24/7 so that you know
learn that lesson the hard way but wish
we had done that when it comes to adding
new things to the game obviously we have
the wastelanders coming up we have the
new mode the battle royale mode I mean
how do you kind of determine what is
going to get lumped together into one
big sort of expansion ask rather than
goodbye a little patch bit by bit
well wastelanders it's it's the workload
in terms of you know how long that
contents going to take to create nuclear
winter the battle royale mode we had
started a while ago like hey how do we
handle PvP what's a good PvP mode for
our game that people would enjoy we
tried some things and then we knew hey
let's let's release it for e3 and make
it a free week that's where okay
that'll help everybody jump in it's
doing amazing the team is so excited to
see because you worry a little bit are
people gonna kind of be cynical about a
battle royale but the feedback has been
incredible how was the workflow change
within Bethesda Game Studios going from
you know previous games that used to
just you know you release and then maybe
you do a big DLC six months later a year
later how is the workflow changed and
what have you kind of learned
that in the transition to this living
this game that you're trying to make out
like a platformer our team in Austin who
is amazing
Doug Mellencamp Chris Mayer all the
people there there they started MMOs you
know with Ultima Online and other things
and Star Wars and they know that world
really well which is why we wanted to
work with them and so they've been
incredible at this cadence of updating
and doing all that so it it comes with
scale and it was we have people that are
on Star field doing it's a new game but
still things that we're more used to and
then we have this live service part that
we're not used to but we have people who
have who are experts in that and it that
parts go on the pace of updating and the
updates really proud of the work that's
been done that part has actually gone
incredibly well for our first kind of go
at this when it comes to looking at
other Bethesda properties have you been
looking at Elder Scrolls online at all
in terms of how they've approached
making a live game yeah that fire and
his team over at ZeniMax online they've
been incredibly helpful through this
process because they went through a
similar one you know when that game
launched and what it is today
so that's been helpful in how we to your
question before how do you figure out
what things to work on they've been
helpful and how to prioritize I'm
curious like playing devil's advocate of
it when you look at games like destiny
that have you know like a somewhat rocky
launch back when it first released you
look at games like fallout 76 you look
at this and it's still a new thing
relatively right these games as service
which has kind of become a buzzword and
then there's like the subset of people
that say like if you haven't finished
the game don't release it but are they
missing the point or do they have a
point or no absolutely have a point you
know if you don't feel great about it
don't release it we felt very good about
it we knew that there was a potential
for things because it was our first go
we knew that destiny a game that we
loved wasn't well reviewed when it came
out which I personally thought well we
can do but I don't want to talk about
other people's scores and but a lot of
these games ethically online Survival
games but we still wanted to do it right
and so I don't think it's a
hey hey ship it in this this and then it
will become this the looking at those
games their long-term fate was even if
it was great at launch if they didn't
maintain and keep listening to the
community those games kind of died out
so it's you really want to have both I'm
putting myself in your shoes and maybe
this is presumptuous but I'm looking at
fallout 76 I have starfield on the way I
have Elder Scrolls 6 on the way at some
point yeah I think to me it would be
tempting to say okay we have this games
as service fault
model for the fallout 76 it's tough to
keep updating it's tough to sift through
all this feedback like Lucy mentioned
like it's tempting to say let's just go
back to the old format with starfield
Elder Scrolls 6 what's your what is
what's your kind of thinking on like the
future of Bethesda's formats with these
beings that's that's why we're larger
right we knew we had to scale up to do
these things so you're not sacrificing
one for the other we have a full team on
star field now and we have a full team
on 76 and we have a full team on mobile
and one of the benefits with having a
large you know some more scale is when
one of the projects needs more staff we
have that luxury so when 76 is kind of
in it's real hey we need some more
people there store some things up last
year then then we were able to move
resources around so it's kind of the
best of both worlds but we don't want to
we're only really picking one over the
other when it's about to come out or
when there when there are key issues and
we can take longer something like
starfield
can it's been three and a half years
we've been on that and so it kind of
starts slow it gets more people and then
they need to move some here and now it's
it really is a full team on that game so
with the full team being on that game
I'm just curious I'm I imagine you're
probably gonna be very tight-lipped or
what you can and can't say about it but
when you come to approach designing a
game like that you know you have all
this experience in fantasy and all this
experience and you know post-apocalyptic
post-apocalyptic and then you're
approaching something that's sci-fi but
also with essences of something
completely new what are you drawing from
the star field
well that's a loaded question other than
you know it'll be a time we talk about
that but actually it's a fair one in
that there's a lot of science fiction
there's lesson games actually it's more
in movies and television and for us they
you know that's a world an IP and game
we've thought about for a decade
it's our first new IP in 25 years and
our goal is that it it has this
uniqueness where it stands up with
Fallout in Elder Scrolls and star filled
that that it's it's own thing and it has
its we spend a lot of time on tone not
just game flow but how does it feel so
you look at it and you say you know
that's star field versus Star Trek or
Star Wars way up okay so unfortunately I
think I've time for one last question I
do want to ask you so you say if you
could go back in time you would have
done 24/7 beta would have allowed you
some more flexibility going into the
release right is there anything I say
and made access to that very very easy
for people because you're not gonna get
enough right is there any sense I know
like based on what you saying at the
conference like it feels like it feels
like from within the team year to is
like a turning point I don't know if
it's morbid or binary to say it's a
do-or-die moment for Fallout 76 because
there are these vibrant communities
within the game but do you feel as if
this is the moment where it could go one
of two ways I that is a little morbid
I think the wild Appalachia update we
did in the spring that was a cadence
over several months of this was content
we were dropping and that's where we saw
the game start to turn where hey the
player base is really loving what we're
doing and we're getting in a faster
cadence with some meteor updates so
after seeing how that went were we're
big believers awesome well Todd thank
you so much for coming on having me yeah
I appreciate you being so candid great
night you know I love these questions
and it's it's good to talk about it well
good luck with everything looking
forward everybody if you're watching
here in person or you are at home we are
gonna be right back shortly with Ghost
Recon breakpoint so don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Applause]